اذا مشاهدينا شكرا لخالد واهلا بكم من
استوديوهاتنا في الرياض الى دبي ولا زالت
التغطيه مستمره ساعات طويله مضت على فاجعه
الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا ولكن تداعيات هذه
الكارثه متواصله حصيله الضحايا بارتفاع
مستمر صور مباشره ننقلها لكم دائما والان
تشاهدونها للدمار الهائل في هذه المنطقه
اكثر من 11 الف قتيل في زلزال سوريا
وتركيا حتى الان جهود الاغاث الاغاثه لا
زالت تتواصل وذلك في سباق مع الزمن على
امل العثور على ناجين وطبعا معكم والعربيه
على مدار الساعه في تغطيه مستمره لهذا
الحدث الجلل
ومشاهدينا نشاهد الدمار الهائل الذي خلفه
الزلزال في تركيا في انطاكيا تحديدا طبعا
مباني استوت على الارض كما نشاهد ومن تحت
هذه الانقاذ هناك اناس طبعا عمليات
الانقاذ لا زالت مستمره لا زال العاملون
على الارض ياملون بان يكون هناك احياء تحت
الانقاذ لم يتم الاعلان حتى هذه اللحظه
رغم مرور الساعات الطويله لم يتم الاعلان
عن التحول من مرحله الانقاذ الى مرحله
انتشال الجثث لازال العاملون يتبعون سياسه
الصمت في كثير من الاحيان على امل ان
يسمعوا صوت من هم قد يكونوا تحت الانقاض
وعلى قيد الحياه كانت هناك صور مؤلمه خلال
اليومين الماضيين حتى هذه اللحظه لانتشال
الجثث من تحت الانقاض عائلات باكملها قد
اختفت
جراء هذا الزلزال ولكن بالايضا ايضا كان
هناك بعض الصور التي تعطينا بعض الامكان
لاطفال او لعائلات استطاعت ان تخرج من تحت
الانقاض وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تظهر بين
اللحظه والاخرى العديد من الحالات والقصص
الانسانيه التي نشاهدها هناك دعم دولي
هائل وصل الى الولايات المتحده والتي طبعا
تفرض عقوبات على سوريا وعلى النظام السوري
ولكن رغم ذلك الجانب الانساني والقضايا
الانسانيه ضغط على كافه الخلافات الموجوده
في المنطقه على مستوى اقليمي على مستوى
محلي وايضا على مستوى دوله وذلك بحشد
الجهود لدعم المتضررين ان كان في تركيا او
في سوريا الجريحه نقول الجريحه لانه
الامكانيات المتوفره في سوريا ليست على
حالها كما هو الوضع في تركيا ولكن هناك
دعم الان فتح مبررات الانسانيه وايضا
محاوله من كافه الدول السعوديه اعلنت في
هذا اليوم عن بدء حملتها لدعم المتضررين
كان هناك اعلان ان الدعم بدا حتى قبل
اطلاق هذه الحمله الشعبيه داخل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اكثر من دوله ايضا
الامارات سخرت الجهود لنقل المساعدات
السعوديه فتحت ممر جوي كما قالت طبعا لا
نعرف التفاصيل ولكن نحاول الوصول اليها في
سياق النشره وحديثنا ان كان مع المراسلين
او من هم على الارض
[موسيقى]
الله يقويك يا رب ويرضى عليك
شفت واحد اجره
نامت
قول يا رب
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر يا رب الله اكبر الحمد لله
الحمد لله على السلامه
ريح ريح ريح ريح ريح
[موسيقى]
تمام تمام
طبعا صور موجعه مفرحه منها والمحزنه ايضا
حصيله ضحايا مرعبه في سوريا وتركيا
يتجاوزت بحسب اخر الاحصاءات كما ذكرنا قبل
قليل احد عشر الف قتيل في كلا البلدين
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اعلن
ارتفاع الحصيله في بلاده لتصل الى ثمانيه
الاف وخمسمائه قتيل فيما قاربت الاصابات
من 50 الف حاله اما في سوريا فقد قدر
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان اعداد القتلى
ب
2771 في حصيله مرجحه ايضا للارتفاع
لمزيد معنا من اضنه زيدان زنكلو مراسل
العربيه زيدان اهلا بك كنت استمع اليك
وانت تتحاور مع خالد وفي كل مره تقول فيها
بانه علينا ان نصمت سياسه الصمت المتبعه
من قبل عمال الانقاذ او المتطوعين على امل
سماع اي صوت لاي انسان على قيد الحياه هل
لان ذلك ممكن او فقط تمسك بامل زيدان
نعم ميسون والان علينا
نخفض صوتنا قليلا ستشاهدين المشهد الان
عمال الانقاذ اخ له الموقع تماما لفريقنا
المختصين سيدخل لمعاينه الموقع مره اخرى
هناك اشارات وصلت لفرق الانقاذ ميسون
حقيقه الصمت يطلبون الجميع عفوا يطلبون من
الجميع ان الصمت واطفاء الالات حتى
يتمكنوا من سماع الاصوات يوم امس كنا معهم
هنا في هذا الموقع وفعلا لمرتين خلال
ساعتين متتاليتين سمعوا اصوات وكان هناك
فرح عارض في هذا المكان والموقع طبعا يعني
نتحدث عن فرح مع غصه الى ان الفرح دائما
او الامل يترافق الامل بوجود ناجين يترافق
مع اخراج بعض الجثث من هذا المكان خرجت
جثث صباح هذا اليوم لذلك مشاعر مختلطه
وترقب ولحظات عصيبه صحيح حقيقه ميسون كما
تشاهدين الموقع اخليه تماما كان هناك ايضا
افراد من الجيش التركي مع عناصر الانقاذ
الموقع وتم اخلاقه قبل دقائق فقط قبل ان
نكون معكم عن الهواء الان كما تشاهدون احد
افراد الجيش التركي ما زال متواجدا هناك
مع بعض العناصر من الفرق المختصه التي
جلبت اجهزه متطوره وكلاب مدربه جابت هذا
الموقع عده مرات وحددت مواقع قالت احد
عناصر الانقاذ ان الفرق المختصه تمكنت من
رصد اشارات ربما يكون هناك على عمق ما بين
2.4 الى 2.8
ربما يكون هناك اشخاص ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه فرق الانقاذ لم تستطع تاكيد هذا
الموضوع بشكل او المختصون لم يؤكدوا هذا
الموضوع بشكل حقيقي لكن عندما استمرت
عمليات الحفر كنا هنا نراقب هذا الموضوع
بترقب شديد بمعنى التكبير من عناصر
الانقاذ بشكل كبير جدا وعندما سالنا عن
هذا الموضوع قالوا ان هناك احد الاشخاص ما
زال على قيد الحياه لكن عمليه اخراج هذا
الشخص على ما يبدو انها وهي حقيقه عمليه
معقده وصعبه يجب ان يتم الحفر بادوات
بسيطه بحيث لا يؤدي الى انهيارات على
المكان الذي يتواجد فيه الشخص العالق تحت
الانقاذ وتحت الركام لا تستخدم الالات
العملاقه الات الحفر العملاق والت ازاله
الركام الا في محيط الموقع لازال لافساح
او تسهيل وصول الفرق الانقاذ اكثر لكن في
المنطقه المستهدفه التي يتوقع ان يكون
فيها اشخاص
موجودين سواء كان هناك شكوك انهم على قيد
الحياه او حتى ان كان هناك تيقن او يقين
ان هناك جثث يتم الحفر باليات بسيطه
ورويه وهدوء شديد حتى لا يؤدي كما ذكرنا
الى انهيارات على ان هذه العمليه برمتها
ليست عمليه سهله ميسون هناك المباني
المجاوره لهذا المبنى المدمر فيها تشققات
يعني اذا استطاع زميلي ان ينتقل الى
المبنى المجاور هناك تشققات ايضا مبنى
مكون من 14 طابقا اخلي بالكامل فيه تشققات
وتصدعات يمكن لا قدر الله في حال كان هناك
هزات ارتداديه يمكن ان يكون هناك انهيارات
لكن نعمل ان لا يحدث هذا السيناريو طبعا
السؤال زيدان
مضطره نعم مضطر واعطيك مجال للصمت على
الاقل بعد الدقائق ان اشير الى اعداد
القتلى في سوريا لانه بدانا النشره
بالحديث عن انه الاعداد
وصلت الى 2771 الان نتابع على الهواء
مباشره للائتلاف الوطني السوري يقول انه
اعداد القتلى في سوريا تعدى الثلاثه الاف
قتيل بسبب الزلزال هناك وطبعا لا زالت
اعمال
الانقاذ مستمره زيدان عندي سؤال فيما
يتعلق بمن يمكن ان يكون تحت الانقاذ نستمع
الى ارقام مختلفه 11 الف نستمع عن
العصابات هل هناك من رصد لمن هو داخل هذا
المبنى من قبل العائلات بمعنى اخر انه هل
هناك من ينتظر من يبلغ هل من رقم ساخن يتم
التواصل
عبره
لتسجيل ربما من اختفى حتى الان
حتى الان عمليه احصاء المفقودين مستحيله
نحاول سماع بعض الصرخات المفرقه الانقاذ
هناك
ربما يحاولون
[موسيقى]
نستمع قليلا
سنتابع الصوره ونتمنى يعني ان يكون هناك
خبر جيد بعد قليل اتركك لتتبع سياسه الصمت
الان حيث نشاهد مباشره كيف رجال الانقاذ
يحاولون الاستماع ان كان هناك اي صوت لاي
من الاحياء تحت الانقاد واعود اليك ولكن
سنتابع الصوره فقط
وبهذا الوقت انتقل الى هاتاي مفرد العربيه
عمار الهندي لينقل لنا المشهد من عنده
عمار
هلا ميسون يعني تحياتي لك ولا زميل زيدان
الخبر المفرح ربما ايضا يحدث هنا في هاتاي
حيث اقف هم منذ ساعه ونصف كانوا يستمعون
الى اصوات اشخاص تحت الانقاض هنا في هذه
الزاويه وبالفعل يبدو ان هذا الشخص على
قيد الحياه لان سياره الاسعاف جاءت للتو
ودخلت تنتظر اخراجه يعني عاده لو لو لم
يكن على قيد الحياه لما جاءت سياره
الاسعاف لنقله ولكن يبدو فعلا انه على قيد
الحياه قبل قليل كانوا رايناهم يدخلوا ماء
له لا نعرف يعني ما اذا كان شاب فتاه سيده
ولكن يعتقد كثيرا بانه ما زال على قيد
الحياه وهم بصدد اخراجه قبل لحظات كانوا
للاسف اخرجوا جستامين ثلاث اشقاء سوريين
يسكنون هذه البنايه وقد توفوا جميعهم وكان
اخرجوا ايضا اجتها مين لسيده وشاب ابنها
ايضا قبله بخمس دقائق يعني هنالك عدد من
الجثامين خرجت من تحت انقاض هذه البنايه
وهذه سياره الاسعاف التي تقف تنتظر اخراج
شخص يعتقد انه على قيد الحياه لانه
اعمالهم تتركز منذ ساعه ونصف في هذه
النقطه التي تشاهدين وهذا التجمهور الذي
يظهر امامك على الشاشه هو لشخص لا يزال
على قيد الحياه كانوا اجتمعوا كانوا طلبوا
منا جميعا ان نصمت ولبضع دقائق وكان هنالك
على ما يبدو رده فعل منه اما بالصوت او
بالحركه وتكرر ذلك وتاكدوا انه على قيد
الحياه ولكن كنا سالنا ما الذي يعيق الامر
كانت هنالك على ما يبدو
اشياء تحيق اخراجه او خروجه من تلك
المنطقه الان هم بصدد نقله او اخراجه لا
يمكن طبعا التنبؤ والتكهن ما اذا كان
سيخرج الان او فيما بعد لان العمليه دقيقه
جدا تحتاج الى صبر وهم بالفعل يعملون
بعدد كبير جدا لاخراج هذا الشخص الذي لا
يزال على قيد الحياه في المقابل للاسف كما
قلت لك هنالك من اخرجوهم جثث هامل في هذا
المبنى
نعم نعم توفوا في هذا المبنى وكان للاسف
يعني نحن هنا تقريبا من ساعتين كانوا
قالوا انه عمليات البحث في هذا المبنى
للاسف كانت تاخرت بسبب الارباك والضغط
الكبير من الاعداد الكبيره للمباني
المنهاره والعمليات اللوجستيه الجاريه في
كل ولايه هاتاي وانت تعرفي
تتصدر قائمه الولايات والمدن التركيه
الاكثر ت من هذا الزلزال وحتى ربما في
اعداد الوفيات لرقم لدي ولكن سياره
الاسعاف التي تظهر امامك هذه
وصلت للتو
الى الموقع لنقل هذا الشخص الذي يعتقد انه
على قيد الحياه
المنطقه نعم نشاهد عدد كبير من الناس
المحيطين متطوعين المنطقه مفتوحه او انه
مغلقه من هم هؤلاء او هم من اهالي الضحايا
نعم
هنالك اسر الضحايا قبل قليل حينما اخرجوا
جثامين جاؤوا اسرهم وتعرفوا عليهم فورا
لان هذه افضل طريقه للتعرف على الجثامين
قبل وصولها الى المستشفيات وبالتالي ربما
يعني التسبب في مشكلات للتعرف عليهم
يعني كل الاسر تتجمر وتتجمع في البنايات
التي فيها مفقودين في حال خروجهم يعني
متوفين يتعرفوا عليهم فورا قبل نقلهم الى
المستشفيات حتى تسهل عمليه التعرف عليهم
وهنالك متطوعين من المدنيين ومن سكان
هاتاي وهنالك فرق الصليب الاحمر والدفاع
المدني التركي وهنالك فرق متطوعه تقوم
بتوزيع مساعدات على الاسر التي منذ ثلاث
يعني منذ ان حدث الزلزال يقفون هنا حول
البنايات التي فيها المفقودين المنطقه
مفتوحه طبعا ولكنها عده بنايات
سقطت الى جانب بعضها البعض وبعض البنايات
لم تسقط مائله اذا كانت الصوره هنالك على
اليمين تشاهديها ميسون ستتضح لك الفكره
هنالك بنايات تميل بشكل كبير ولكنها لم
تنهار بعد ولذلك هنالك تخوف واليوم صباحا
تحديدا كان هنالك تخوف لان هنالك هزتين
ارتداديتين كانت حدثت صباحا واحده منها
اربع درجات فاصله خمسه وشعرنا بها في في
هاتاي الحقيقه انه المدينه مدمره بالكامل
ومنكوبه بالكامل وعمليات البحث مستمره في
كل مكان فيه بنايه قد سقطت طبعا كنت كنت
استمعت ايضا الى سؤالك الى زيدان عن اعداد
المفقودين تحت الانقاب في
معرفه ارقامهم او عددهم هذا الامر صعب جدا
لانه تخيلي لك ان تتخيلي ان بنايه مثلا
واحده يصعب التكهن بعدد الاشخاص الذين
يتواجدون فيها ولكن هذا الامر لن يظهر الا
بعد ان تنتهي فعلا عمليات الانقاذ الانقاض
من كل
الولايات والمدن التركيه هذه عمليه
الانقاذ التي يعني انا اركز عليها جدا
لانها فعلا ستبعث الامل كثيرا لدى الناس
لانه اليوم لم تسجل في هاتاي ايه عمليه
انقاذ لاشخاص ناجين تحت الانقاذ ان كان
هنالك شخص ناجن سيكون الاول اليوم الذي
يخرج ناجي فيه من تحت الانقاذ لذلك طبعا
الكل بالانتظار وكما نشاهد عمليات الانقاذ
مستمره باكثر من موقع واجهه الصوره في
اعلى الشاشه الى اليسار طبعا مشاهدينا هي
صوره
بانوراميه
للدمار في انطاكيا احدى المناطق التي
تدمرت بشكل ايضا كبير نشاهد ايضا الدخان
يتصاعد ولكن رغم ذلك الا ان عمليات
الانقاذ لا زالت مستمره لا زال هناك امل
بخروج ناجين كما ذكر مراسلنا الان قبل وهو
يتحدث معنا من هاتاي عمار الهندي قال بان
هناك سمع صوت لشخص يؤمل بان يكون يعني على
قيد الحياه عندما يتم انتشاله خاصه انه
العمليه صعبه ويجب ان يكون هناك نوع من
الحذر في التعاطي مع عمليه الانقاذ عمار
هناك مساعدات من المفترض بانها بدات تنطلق
من دول مختلفه وايضا من الداخل التركي هل
تلمستم ذلك وماذا عن من هم على قيد الحياه
اذا مصحه التعبير في منطقه منكوبه اين
يلجاون
صحيح صحيح نعم لاحظنا طبعا منذ الصباح
ليله امس لم تكن تشهد اي حركه طيران فوق
هاتاي اليوم صباحا منذ الصباح طائرات
عسكريه كبيره جدا ومروحيات وطائرات
يعني طبيه تنقل مساعدات وتطير على مستويات
منخفضه هنا في هاتاي هذا رايته يعني عشرات
المرات منذ الصباح وبالتالي نعم هنالك
مساعدات على ما يبدو لهذه المدينه
المنكوبه تصل تباعا وبكثافه
من مختلف الجهات لا استطيع ان احدد اسماء
الجهات هذه لانها عبر الجو ولكن ليله امس
حينما جئنا الى هاتاي ووصلنا كانت هنالك
شاحنات كبيره تحمل اعلام دول اوروبيه ودول
عربيه تاتي بالمساعدات الناس هنا ميسون من
من تبقوا في هذه المدينه المنكوبه هم
الاشخاص الذين ينتظرون تحديد مصير
اقربائهم او ذويهم المتواجدين تحت الانقاض
ولكن الجميع خرج من المدينه لانه في
الواقع يعني ليس هنالك امان حتى ان تكون
في داخل داخل بنايه نحن مثلا وقلتها من
قبل نحن بدنا في السياره لان هنالك خوف ان
تستاجر حتى فندق واساسا جميع الفنادق في
هذه المدينه لا تعمل بامر من الحكومه
لانها ضمن حاله الطوارئ وبالتالي منعوا ان
تكون الفنادق ان يشغلها احد وبالتالي من
لديه احد يذهب اليه في مدينه اخرى ذهب
اليه ولكن الحكومه التركيه قامت بايجاد
مخيمات خيام على بعد يعني بعيد عن المباني
المدمره للاسر التي تحتاج والتي تهاجرت من
مساكنها ولكن مهما كان ميسون الحال صعب
جدا نعم بس خلينا نعطي بارقه امل كوننا
ننتظر ان نسمع شيء عن هذا الرجل الذي سمع
صوته تحت الانقاذ لانه وكاله الاناضول
تتحدث عن ان هناك
عمليه لانقاذ وقد تم انقاذ مسنه في قهرمان
مرعش بعد بقائها الانقاض لسته وخمسين ساعه
يعني اتمنى ان يكون هذا الخبر هو بارقه
امل
يعني نحن نتمسك باي معلومه صغيره تعطينا
الامل على انه يمكن ان يكون هناك من هم
على قيد الحياه لا زالوا تحت هذه الانقاذ
رغم مرور كل هذه الساعات عمار عندما نتحدث
عن ان الوضع صعب وانتم كاعلاميين وغيركم
كيف وضعكم كيف تتحركون واين تبقون
وضع يعني الوفود الاعلاميه مطمئن هنالك
حريه في التحرك في التغطيه في كل شيء ولكن
صراحه يعني نحن ننام في سياراتنا طبعا انا
سالت زملاء من مؤسسات اعلاميه اخرى اجنبيه
ينامون في سياراتهم لانه وتواجدك في اي
مبنى قد يعرضك للخطر صراحه لانه هنالك
تحذير اساسا من السلطات فيها تاي بان
الهزات الارتداديه قد تؤدي الى انهيار
المباني التي تضررت بشكل جزئي في الزلزال
في المره الاولى والثانيه حينما ضربها
تركيا ولذلك الجميع ينام في سيارته في
مناطق بعيده عن البنايات وهذا ما نفعله
عموما يعني
مربكه امكانيه للحصول بسهوله على الماء
يعني المشرب والماكل وبالمقابل يعني
الحاجات الخاصه لاي انسان وهل بالانقطاع
بالتيار الكهربائي لازال قائم لانه قالوا
انه في كثير من المناطق قطعت الكهرباء
قطعه المياه وغيره
حتى صباح اليوم كانت هاتاي بلا كهرباء
بشكل كامل لاني انا يعني وصلتها وليس فيها
كهرباء
خصوصا وسط وسط هاتاي ولكن في الطعام الماء
كل شيء متوفر هنالك من يوزع الماء في
الطرقات يعني فرق متطوعين يعني متبرعين
يوزعون شرب شربه العدس مثلا اطعمه خفيفه
جدا يسهل توزيعها للناس وهنالك شاهدت بام
عين اشخاص يعني ينامون في الشارع لانه ليس
لديهم مكان ينامون فيه ويبدو انهم من
الذين ينتظرون عمليات الانقاذ تصل الى
بنايات فيها من اشخاص ربابهم ولكنه كما
قلت واقول مجددا بعض البنايات في هاتاي لم
تبدا فيها بعد عمليات الانقاذ نعم ميسون
على كنا نعطيك الوقت ونتمنى ان نستمع منك
بعد قليل
على اخبار جيده
فيما يتعلق كما ذكرنا صوت شخص تحت هذا
المبنى الذي نشاهده على الهواء مباشره
نامل ان يكون على قيد الحياه على انتشاله
من الانقاد مفرد العربيه عمار الهندي ابقى
معنا ولكن سننتقل الان الى مراسلين اخرين
نعود اليك في سياق هذه النشره ونشرات اخرى
من غازي عنتاب معنى موفد العربيه غسان ابو
اللوز ومعنى من القامشلي مراسل العربيه
جمعه كاش جمعه انقل لنا المعلومات
المتوفره لديك
مرحبا بك وبجميع زملاء المنتشرين في تركيا
واستاذ المشاهدين يعني المشهد في الطرف
السوري لا يختلف كثيرا عما يبدو عليه
الحال في الطرف التركي عمليات اتشال الجثث
والبحث عن جيم مستمره وتسير بوثيره على
عندما يتم سماع الاصوات العلاقين تحت
المباني والاضار كلها في هذه المرحله تتجه
نحو بلده جنديرس الكرديه التي يعني هي
الاكثر تضررا على مستوى سوريا بالكامل 84
مبنى مدمر فرق الانقاذ لم تصل الا الى
حوالي 20 مبنى منذ الصباح كانت اصوات
الاطفال والنساء تسمع من تحت روكان بعض
المباني المنهاره وبالتالي اتجهت اليها
فرق الانقاذ هناك بارقه امل تم منحه لسكان
الشمال الغربي عندما وصل
مصري وهو الاول الذي يدخل الى هذه المنطقه
الى عموم مناطق المعارضه فريق طبي وفريق
متخصص في
الانقاذ من خلال المعابر التي فتحت ام
ماذا خبرنا عن المعابر وامكانيه التحرك
الان والمساعدات والدعم الطب المتوقع
ميسون هذا هذا الفريق دخل من مرافق النظام
لذلك يعني يعد يعني خطوه غير مسبوقه ربما
يعني يمهد الطريق في المناطق الكروس مناطق
التماس يعني يفتح
المناطق المغلقه امام يعني الفرق الطبيه
او حتى امام المساعدات الانسانيه بالتدفق
من مناطق النظام حتى الى مناطق
المعارضه لذلك يعول على هذا الفريق بان
يكون يعني بدايه لدخول الفرق من من
المناطق النظام بينما ميسون معبر باب
الهوى لم يستقبل سوى الجثث يعني وفق
معلوماتنا استقبل معبر باب الهواء حوالي
100 جثه لسوريين قضوا داخل الاراضي
التركيه ووصلت جتامينهم الى هذا المعبر
وتوزعت على جميع المدن او بالمدن السوريه
ولا يزال هذا المعبر يستقبل الجثه القادمه
من تركيا دون ولكن لا مساعدات جمعه لا
مساعدات هذا ما تقول جمعه لانه في حديث عن
انه في ثلاثه معابر فتحت الان انسانيه
لا هناك معبر الراعي باب الهوى وباب باب
السلام هذه المعابر الثلاث لم يدخل منها
السياره واحده تحمل مساعدات انسانيه كل
السيارات التي دخلت منها تحمل جثه
للسوريين وهذا وفق تاكيد يعني مصدر رفيع
مستوى داخل هذا داخل هذا عشان نعطي
المعلومه مزبوطه كونك تستمع من جهات معينه
حول هذه المعلومات لم تدخل مساعدات لانها
لا تتواجد حتى الان بمعنى نحن بانتظار
وصول هذه المساعدات في ظل بدء الحملات
والزخم الذي بدا يظهر من قبل كافه الدول
وصل حتى الولايات المتحده او لا لانه
ممنوعه حتى الان في معلومات ان كان هناك
تكدس ربما للشاحنات التي تحمل المساعدات
الطبيه وغيرها او لا
حتى الان لم تدخل اي مساعدات من المعابر
الثلاثه التي قالت ان هي تتفاوض بانها
اتفقت مع تركيا على فتح هذه المعابر يعني
اضيف لك امرا اخر يعني وفق مسؤول رفيع
المستوى في معبر باب الهواء قال بان
الاتراك لا يسمحون بدخول المساعدات يعني
غالبا الاتراك لا يسمحون بدخول المساعدات
ولكن يعني حتى تعمل المنظمات الدوليه
بانها تتحدث تتحجج بان الطرق الى هذا الى
معبر باب الاول الاساسي طبعا بان طرق
مكسره ومقطوعه فتساءل وقال لي تساءل قال
لماذا تصلنا السيارات التي تحمل الجثث ولا
يقولون بان يعني الطرق معطله ولماذا لا
تاتي المساعدات الانسانيه هكذا قال لي
حرفيا هذا المسؤول الان يعني الرهان على
هذه المعابر الثلاث على الدول التي وعدت
باد مساعدات نحن نعرف ان هناك دول كثيره
سوف تستخدم المطارات التركيه وخاصه المطار
غازي عنتاب وهاتاي القريبين من هذا
لاثقال مساعدات لكن حتى اللحظه يصل اي شيء
سوريا بحسب المعلومات الان
طالبت
بقائمه طويله من الاحتياجات الطبيه طبعا
العاجله لاغاثه المنكوبين لا اعلم ان كان
هذا يشمل كافه المناطق او لا ولكن ذكرت في
البدايه انه هناك فريق طبي مصري دخل الى
اراضي المعارضه من اراد النظام اشاره
ايجابيه خبرنا عن حجم هذا الفريق واين
يتوزع ويتركز الان العمل جمعه
يعني هذا الفريق مقسم الى قسمين فريق
متخصص في الارهاب سوف يساعد فرق الدفاع
المدني في مسالات البحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاض وهناك فريق طبي مؤلفا مجموعه من
الاطباء
يعني هؤلاء الاطباء لديهم اقتصاصات يعني
مطلوبه في الداخل السوري ارجاء عمليات
جراحيه دقيقه هذا الفريق دخل الى مدينه
حلب من مغناطق النظام وعلى الاغلب سيتجه
يعني سيكون خطف مساره بلده جنديرس التي
تشهد يعني اكبر عدد من الوفيات وفيات
ارتفع الى 600 قتيل وهو العدد الاكبر على
مستوى سوريا في بلده واحده
وايضا قد يساعد المشافي الاخرى المشفى خاص
بمشفى تشرين عفوا مشفى عفرين
العسكري وقد ينتقل ربما الى مشفى ادب
المركزي فيه ايضا اعداد كبيره من
المصابين كما قلت ميسون يشكل هذا دخول هذا
الفريق امل جديد لدى يعني الماسورين
العالقين يعني السوريين المنكوبين في
مناطق المعارضه بان يتبعوا فرق اخرى ويمهد
ايضا لدخول المساعدات من المعابر التي ظلت
مغلقه منذ ساعات السبعين الماضيه وحتى
الان بين مناطق التماس بين بين النظام
والمعارضات طيب اتمنى من جميع مفاتيح
العربيه ومراسليها البقاء معنا
وننتقل الى هاتاي موفد العربيه هناك عمار
الهندي ومعنى ايضا من غازي عنتاب مفرد
العربيه غسان ابو لوز وابدا معك غسان
المعلومات انقل لنا الاجواء من عندك
والاخبار
نعم ميسون نحن في بلده الاصلاحيه في غازي
عنتاب وهي من اكثر البلدات تضررا هي بلده
من كوبا حسب رئيسه البلديه هناك 50% من
مباني هذه البندله انهارت فوق
ساكنيها فوق رؤوس ساكنيها ما زالت عمليات
الانقاذ مستمره وما زالت عمليات المساعده
تتوالى الى هذه البلده تباعا تم اجلاء
المواطنين وسكان من المنازل والبيوت وكما
تشاهدين خلفي في الصوره هذه الاليات تعمل
على مدار الساعه منذ اليوم الاول لمحاوله
انقاذ من هم عالقين تحت الانقاض كما
تشاهدين ايضا في هذه الصوره هؤلاء الاشخاص
لهم اقارب داخل هذا المبنى وهو مكون من
خمس طوابق انهار هذا المبنى بشكل كامل وهم
ينتظرون منذ ايام
انتشال ما يمكن انتشاله من تحت هذه
على امل ان يكون هناك ناجين تحت هذه تحت
طبقات هذا المبنى العدد ليس واضح هناك من
يقول بان هناك عشره اشخاص وهناك من يقول
ان هناك اكثر من ذلك تحت هذا المبنى وهذا
ينطبق على عموم البلدات المباني الموجوده
في هذه المنطقه خلف هذه الايه الاليات
شارع طويل اغلب المباني منهاره بشكل كامل
ميسون في هذا الشارع وايضا هناك مباني
ايله للسقوط ايضا ومبالي متشققه لا تصلح
للاستخدام البشري وبالتالي تقوم السلطات
باخلاء الناس طبعا اخلتهم
نقلوهم الى مراكز ايواء والى خيام وايضا
هناك عمليات نقل من هذه المناطق لمن يريد
الى مناطق اخرى سواء كان بالسيارات او
بالطيران الخطوط الجويه التركيه قالت
بانها ستنقل 30 الف شخص من المناطق المتضر
الى مناطق اخرى اما المباني المتضرره
والايله لسقوط تقوم ايضا السلطات هنا
بهدمها بالاليات الثقيله حتى لا تشكل خطر
مستقبلا على حياه المواطنين عمليا عمليات
الاغاثه مستمره حجم الكارثه هائل وكبير
جدا الفرق الانقاذ ما زالت تواصل عمليات
الانقاذ
حاولت انتشال منهم تحت ومتمسك بالامل على
ان يكون هناك من هم احياء وبدانا بالنشره
بالحديث طبعا مع
مراسلنا طبعا
عمار الذي كان يقول بان هناك امكانيه ان
يكون هناك فيها طاي تحت مبنى احد الاحياء
عمار باختصار اي جديد
نعم ميسون بالفعل انا كنت استفسرت منذ
قليل يبدو انها سيده
وهي على قيد الحياه فعلا في هذه المنطقه
التي يتجمر فيها المنقذون
وجاءت سياره الاسعاف وهنالك ايضا مسعفون
ويبدو ان هذه السيده معها ابنتها ولكن لا
تاكيد بانه الاحياء هم يعني الام وابنتها
ولذلك تاكيد بانه على ما يبدو هنالك سيده
فعلا على قيد الحياه وانهم الان يعملون
على اخراجها بطريقه تضمن سلامتها وسلامه
حياتها في المقابل هنالك في الجهه اليمنى
ايضا يبدو انهم سمعوا صوتا ايضا هل الان
وهم يعملون على ازاله الانقاظ هذا ما يحدث
ميسون هم يعملون وفي حال سماع اي صوت او
اي اشاره بان هنالك احياء تتوقف عمليات
عمل الثقيله تنتقل العمليات الى ادوات
خفيفه وبسيطه لضمان عدم الحاق اي اذى
الشخص الذي يتواجد تحت الانقاض على قيد
الحياه نحن الان حاله مؤكده بان هنالك شخص
على قيد الحياه وسنعود اليك لمعرفه المزيد
ولكن اسمح لي ان انتقل الان لنستمع الى
كلمه رئيس الهيئه العليا للانقاذ في سوريا
تزامن مع
جهود كل المؤسسات والوزارات لاعاده
ترميم ما تضرر من خدمات وبنى تحتيه بكل
الجهات المعنيه
سواء شبكات الكهرباء او المياه او
الاتصالات او
كل الخدمات طبعا ترافق ايضا مع استنفار
الوزارات المعنيه بتقديم الخدمات الغذائيه
وبكل اشكالها بحيث ان لا نفقد اي خدمه او
ماده كالخبز او غيرها ايضا تزامن مع
ضخ كميات
زائده من المحروقات باتجاه المحافظات
المنكوبه طبعا نعلم ان المحافظات هي
حلب واللاذقيه وحماه وطرطوس وايضا في ادلب
كل هذه الجهود تتكامل لتؤدي الرساله وهي
ان الانسان السوري هو الاسماء وهو الهدف
وهو محور ما ينصب عليه كل الجهد الرسمي
والاهلي وهذا ما يتم بروح عاليه من
التضامن والتكامل فيما بيننا جميعا كما
قلت الوفيات لغايه هذه اللحظه 1262
ضحيه
الجرحى 2285 لغايه هذه اللحظه طبعا هذه
الارقام تتطور تباعا وفق تقدم عمليات
الانقاذ بشكل كامل
وعمليات الانقاذ اثمرت عدد لا باس به كما
قلت ان الالف 1285 من المصابين هم بنهايه
المطاف متاثرين ومتضررين وجزء كبير منهم
تم
انتشاله من تحت الانقراض بعد القيام
بالمعالجات اللازمه
اما ما يخص الايواء فقد تم افتتاح 180
مركز ايواء تضم
الاهالي لكن عدد الاسر التي خرجت من
منازلها لا يقتصر الى على من
لجا الى مراكز الايواء بل انتم تعلمون ان
الكثير من ابناء بلدنا يلجاون الى اقاربهم
الى اماكن اخرى وخصوصا في الارياف بلغ عدد
الاسر او الافراد الذين خرجوا من المنازل
خوفا وهلعا من تصدع هذه المنازل او من
الزلازل
293,829 شخص
طبعا بينهم ايضا اطفال ونساء هذه الارقام
لغايه هذه اللحظه كما اقول
يتم العمل على تقديم كل ما يلزم لهم وترون
ان فرق الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري
الامان السوري للتنميه اللجان
الفرعيه للاغاثه
والجنه العليا الاغاثه كلها الجهود مصبح
على هذا على تقديم كل ما يلزم لاهالينا
طبعا التنظيم الذي ذكرته ينبثق عنه
غرف عمليات في كل محافظه منذ اللحظه
الاولى
شكلت لتحديد
التقسيم المناطق الى قطاعات حسب الضرر
توجيه الامكانات والاليات المتاحه ضمن كل
محافظه الى القطاع
وتحديد الاحتياجات الذي تم تامينه بشكل
كامل
من خلال التنسيق مع غرفه العمليات
المركزيه في دمشق وتعلمون ان الحكومه زجت
بطاقات المحافظات
الاخرى باتجاه المحافظات التي تحتاج الى
اسعاف اكثر من 157 اليه تم زجها من
المحافظات الاخرى لخدمه المحافظات التي
واليوم نحن على تواصل لحظي مع المحافظات
المعنيه
بانقاذ
واكاد اقول انه ما تم قياسا بالامكانات
قياسا بحجم الضرر الذي لحق ببلدنا من
الارهاب وبالاجراءات القسريه احاديه
الجانب
ينم
ويبين عن دوله قويه متكامل
المفاصل بكل قوتها وبكل تلاحمها
ولا ننسى ابدا اي جهد بذل من الجهات
والمحليه والمركزيه اليوم الدفاع المدني
الاطفاء الكوادر الطبيه الفرق الهندسيه
الفنيين من كل اختصاص
بواسل الجيش العربي السوري الذين ضحوا
دفاعا على هذا الوطن هم اليوم على على
طليعه القائمين بكل جهود الاغاثه وجهود
الانقاذ
ومنهم الدفاع المدني ايضا
القوى الامن الداخلي انتم تعلمون ان
المنازل التي
انهارت
تحوي
املاك وارزاق
المتضررين
ولا بد من ضبط الحاله الامنيه وهم شركاء
بكل
عمل يقدم
لعمليات الانقاذ اليوم
نشهد وترون ان الكثير من المبادرين من
منظمات واتحادات وفرق تطوعي شبابيه دعم
بتبرع بالدم
اؤكد اننا نتلقى يوميا المئات من
العروض من ابناء بلدنا جماعاتا وافراد
للمساهمه وتقديم العون والتبرع سواء العين
او النقدي او بالجهد او من خلال مختصين
سواء كانوا فرق طبيه او هندسيه او بكل
الاشكال الدعم المتوقع
طبعا
كما تعلمون تبدا الكارثه كبيره وبالتالي
كانت جهود الدوله السوريه منذ اللحظه
الاولى بنسبه تتجاوز 90% الحمل وقع على
عاتق مؤسسات الدوله السوريه
واجهزتها
وامكاناتها وكانت كما
هو مامول لبت النداء كل الجهات
ولابد من ان نشكر الدول الصديقه التي
بادرت الى تعبير عن تضامنها مع سوريا
وتعلمون ان جزء كبير من قاده العالم
العربي
والاصدقاء
بتواصل مع القياده السوريه
واتصالات مباشره للتعبير عن تضامن وهذا
رصيد لقيادتنا الحقيقه اعطانا الزخم
الكبير وما نشهده اليوم في المطارات هو
ترجمي لهذه
اتصالات ولهذا التضامن الكبير سواء من
الدول الشقيقه او الصديقه
ترون توارد الطائرات محمله بالمواد الطبيه
والاغاثيه
وكلها تصب في نهايه المطاف خدمه
المتضررين من
الزلزال
المدمر الاخير
لا ننكر صعوبه الوضع
ولا ننكر يعني مقارنه
بالامكانات الوضع صعب الطقس الذي صادفنا
بهذه المرحله اللي كان ايضا له اسهل كبير
على عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه
وربما هذه الموجه من
البرد القارس والامطار والرياح القويه
ايضا كانت يعني غير عاديه كل هذا لم يثني
فريق الانقاذ او فرق الانقاذ
الكوادر الاطباء
وكل المسعفين لم
يقل ولا يمل ولم ينقطعوا لحظه واحده ليلا
ونهارا
ودائما وابدا بتنسيق وتكامل بين الفرع
والمركز لحظه بلحظه لتامين كل المتطلبات
وبشكل كامل اريد ان
اطمئن ان
الاهتمام الاول والاولويه في عمل الحكومه
السوريه اليوم لترميم ما تضرر لبلسمه جراح
من من اصيب
والاستكمال اعمال الانقاذ التي نامل ان
تتكلم بالنجاح باكبر قدر ممكن
بهذا المجال على المستوى الاسعاف يتم
اتخاذ كل الاجراءات
وسيتابع هذا الموضوع هناك مستوى متوسط
لتقديم ما يلزم هناك ايضا
تخطيط استراتيجي
ايضا لمعالجه ما حدث لاعاده تقييم المباني
ايضا وضع خطه لاخلاء كل الاباني المباني
الالي للسقوط
وان كان تحتاج الى هدم فلتهدم وان كانت
يكفيها التدعيم ستدعم الامر كما قلت منظم
بكل المراحل مكروه بالنسبه لنا كدوله يعني
بتكامل جهود كل المؤسسات بلا استثناء
اريد ان ايضا
اذكر الدول المشكوره التي قدمت
وتتابعونها وانتم كفريق اعلامي جزء لا
يتجزا من منظومه الدوله السوريه القويه
وانتم تلاحظون اننا نعيش او المواطن
السوري يعيش بشفافيه كل ما يجري وكل ما
يقدم
كانت
من الدول او من الفرق الوطنيه
وردنا
مساعدات من العراق الشقيق من الامارات
العربيه المتحده من ايران من روسيا من
الجزائر من مصر من ليبيا من الاردن الهند
من الباكستان وايضا قيد من باكستان من
ارمينيا وايضا اذا مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا
القدر من هذه الكلمه طبعا لرئيس الهيئه
العليا للانقاذ في سوريا تحدث فيها وربما
التركيز الاول اجمالي عدد القتلى في داخل
المناطق مناطق النظام وصل الى
1262 شخص طبعا المعلومات تتحدث عن انه
الزلزال ان كان في
سوريا او في تركيا قد تعدى 11
الفتيل على كل معنى من دمشق عبر سكايب
الكاتب الصحفي عبد الحميد توفيق اهلا بك
عبد الحميد لنتحدث معا ربما عن الافادات
التي تاتينا من قبل المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها النظام عبد الحميد طبعا استمعنا الى
ربما ايجاز كاف وواف الى اي حد يعكس
الكلمه التي قال فيها بانه لا يمكن انكار
صعوبه الوضع في البلاد بعد الزلزال الحاله
الحقيقيه على الارض
نعم مساء الخير لحضرتك ميسون ولساده
المشاهدين في الحقيقه الوزير الاداره
المحليه او كما يعرف رئيس سجله الاغاثه
الحاليه وقف عند كثير من
الحقائق التي يعمل بها منذ فجر يوم
الاثنين بعد الزلزال بعد تشكيل خلايا
طارئه في كل مكان نعم كان هناك صعوبات
كثيره تواجه الدوله السوريه والحكومه
السوريه في المناطق التي تديرها
وبالتالي كان هناك ايضا عمليات او محاولات
لرفض المحافظات التي تعرضت لهذا الزلزال
الكارثي المدمر غير المسبوق في سوريا ربما
كما تقول بعض الاخبار منذ 300 عام بالتالي
تم رصد
وتحشيد امكانيات الصحيه والاسعافيه وحتى
المشتقات النفط والبترول باتجاه المحافظات
الاربعه التي تضررت حلب وحماه واللاذق جزء
من طرطوس وكذلك جنوب ادلب واتحدث هنا عن
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها الدوله السوريه
ولكن اليوم في الحقيقه المساعدات التي
ترتباعا على
سعيد لو سمحت اسمح لي لانه لدينا صور الان
مباشره لانتشال نتمنى ان تكون امراه كما
قيل مسنه على قيد الحياه لا نعلم حتى الان
ان كانت على قيد الحياه او لا ولكن
المعلومات التي ذكرها عمار كانت تتحدث
عنها وعن ابنتها عمار هل لديك معلومات
صحيح صحيح هي هي سيده وعلى قيد الحياه
والجميع هنا صفق حينما اخرجوها يتم الان
يعني هي على قيد الحياه مئه بالمئه ميسون
وهي سيده نعم كما تحدثنا من قبل الان يعني
ساحاول
نعم ميسون هي سيده والجميع هنا يعني كانت
فرحه عامره صراحه حينما اخرجوها يتم الان
نقلها ميسون الى سياره الاسعاف
نعم هي ميسون شابه وهي مستيقظه تماما
ويعني تحرك شفتيها
وعيونها بشكل طبيعي مئه بالمئه نحن نتحدث
عن شيء عظيم جدا نعم
كنت ذكرت انه امراه مسنه وربما ابنتها
معها هل هي الابنه هذه التي خرجت التي
خرجت شابه ليست ربما في الثلاثين لا اعتقد
ان كانت يعني هي التي كان مقصود انها على
قيد الحياه ولكني اعلم بان هنالك سيده
وابنتها التي خرجت للتو من تحت الانقاضي
شابه وهي مستيقظه مئه بالمئه وانا رايتها
تحرك شفتيها ربما تتحدث بشيء وتحرك اعينها
بشكل طبيعي مئه بالمئه هذا اليوم الثالث
لها تحت الانقاض ميسون وهذا شيء يبعث على
الامل بشكل كبير هذه السياره التي تتواجد
فيها السيده التي تم انقاذها للتو طبعا
منذ ساعتين يعملون على اخراجها من تحت
الانقاذ كانوا اكتشفوا انها على قيد
الحياه ميسون بعد ان سمعوا صوتا وهم هنالك
حاله اغماء على ما يبدو انها من اسره
صعب ان اشرح لك كم كم يعني المشهد مؤثر
جدا الجميع هنا
ذهل فعلا لانه كان الاحباط والياس قد
تغلغل للجميع بانه لا يمكن ان يخرج احد
على قيد الحياه خصوصا اننا في اليوم
الثالث ولكن هذا شيء عظيم جميل جدا ربما
يبعث الامل للالاف في نعم عمار انه الان
التركيز على سياره الاسعاف وعلى من تم
انقاذها ولكن كونها كنا نتحدث عن
ربما امراه اخرى كانت معها تحت الانقاض هل
عاد العاملون ورجال الانقاذ للبحث مجددا
او توقت العم
لا لا ساتابع الان ما اذا كان توقف العمل
او لا استيقظت السيده التي اصيبت بالاغماء
ساتوجه هذه دعيني فقط هذه السيده التي
اصيبت بالاغماء للتو يبدو انها استيقظت
وانه حالها جيده ولكن
ميسون لا على ما يبدو انهم توقفوا عن
البحث يبدو انهم توقفوا عن البحث لا ادري
ربما كانت هذه السيده وحدها ربما هنالك
طبعا هو كمان نشاهد ليس توقف الضوء لا
اخبرني تو بانه يعني فعلا للاسف توقفوا عن
البحث لانهم لم يعودوا يسمعوا الصوت الى
جانب صوتها وانه ربما يعني هي الوحيده
التي كانت ناجيه او نجت من تلك من ذلك
المكان الذي استمر البحث فيه عن تحت
الانقاذ لمده تقريبا ساعتين وتكلل فعلا
بالنجاح باخراج هذه الشابه الثلاثينيه حيه
وانا رايتها يعني مستيقظه تماما من تحت
وبالفعل وسنتابع معك المزيد لانه التغطيه
عمار مستمره ابقى معنا ولكن سننتقل الان
الى استوديوهاتنا في الرياض وخالد لتكمله
هذه التغطيه مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا